[Applaudissements]
ce n'est qu'une décision
sur de nombreux autres pays à travers le monde
oui nous avons entendu euh bien le témoignage de
cassandra fairbanks euh que
les journalistes ont été lus dans les
archives judiciaires cet après-midi
c'est un témoignage très important pour montrer à
quel point politisé jusqu'au plus
haut niveau le  l'affaire julian assange est que
mme fairbanks témoignait qu'elle avait
eu une interaction avec m. schwartz qui est
un
soutien financier du parti républicain
et
largement considéré comme un initié essentiel dans
les cercles d'atout
et il lui a dit des
mois avant l'arrestation de julian à  l'
ambassade
que le plan était en cours, il y a eu des
discussions
dans un cercle d'atout pour négocier avec les
équatoriens pour l'arrêter à l'
ambassade, ce qui s'est produit et puis
bien sûr l'année dernière
le 11 avril et a ensuite été ainsi
confirmé
selon l'interaction qu'elle
a  et elle
avait publié ceci sur Internet et
sur son compte Twitter, une grande partie de l'
interaction
était que Trump avait euh le président Trump
avait
directement ordonné à monsieur grenell alors
ambassadeur
des états-unis en allemagne de
négocier avec l'équatorien au
sujet des arrestations